coronavirus come sopravvivere la
quarantena l'amore ai tempi del
coronavirus cosa come sopravvivere in
cucina ai tempi della quarantena amanda
knox i consigli su come sopravvivere la
40 consigli dalla quarantena da una
ragazza che è stata incarcerata
beh effettivamente
ciao
dio quanto tempo è passato sette mesi 8
oh mamma mamma quante cose sono successe
ma volevo salutarmi volevo sapere come
state voi su instagram iscrivete
tantissimo dicendomi che cercate di
intrattenervi anche con con i miei video
con i miei video vecchi con i video
dello show e ho cercato per giorni il
modo migliore di raccontare nel mio
canale questo periodo che entrerà nella
storia farvi fare un viaggio in quello
che il mio cervello praticamente e
creare questo video con una sorta di
capsula del tempo perché io vorrei
riuscire a e intrappolare quello che io
sto provando in questo periodo
allora innanzitutto lo so il mio sfondo
katamari credo che una delle cose
peggiori di questa quarantena sia
trovare l'intrattenimento giusto c'è
andata un pochino di fortuna con
l'uscita di disney plus ma credo che
quello che più abbia salvato questo
periodo di noi è stato animal crossing
ho anche trovato il vestito dello show e
devo dire che col cappello da cowboy non
sta neanche male e sono tutti molto
grati di questa cosa
soprattutto perché in animal crossing
new horizon è possibile fare la cacca e
giocatori ne sono curiosamente molto
felici e se non siete capaci di farla
non importa ci sono i tutorial come fare
la cacca in animal crossing e provo
molta invidia per questo va terrosa ed è
dal giorno in cui ho creato lo show che
micro i dossier anche perché come
gentilmente mi ricordano da twitter è
passato del tempo come vi ho accennato
ero a milano a girare due video dello
show quando è scoppiata la zona rossa in
lombardia la lombardia gli over 65 non
uscite di casa per due o tre settimane
quando conta fermato uno dei primi
decreti a inizio marzo dove dice che
tutte le manifestazioni tutti gli eventi
sono sospesi fino al 3 aprile
e allora sì che li iniziati l'okay
potrei iniziare ad aver paura ora come
ora è la paura durante un periodo del
genere di essere bloccato fuori casa
perché l'ingresso e l'uscita in
lombardia sarà consentito solo per
motivi gravi indifferibili di lavoro e
di famiglia tu dici cioè io devo tornare
a casa nel mio domicilio posso farlo non
posso farlo aspettare mi informo anche
perché determinate cose se non spiegate
bene in modo semplice creano il panico
quindi tornato a casa con
l'autocertificazione decido di fare
l'unica cosa che posso fare aspettare il
problema è che quando io mi informo
troppo si crea un peso enorme sulla
schiena un po come obelix
anche perché da quel momento in poi ho
iniziato a fare una cosa che non ho mai
fatto in tutta la mia vita passo tutto
il giorno con il cellulare in mano a
scrollare a sinistra per leggere le
ultime notizie e dopo un po diventa
asfissiante perché in mezzo a tutte le
notizie che appaiono ce n'è una che mi
colpisce ogni volta che il bollettino
del corriere che ti fa un resoconto
giornaliero di quanti casi di quanti
morti di quanti guariti ci sono stati in
italia e tenendo come buono il giorno di
contagio 4 marzo possiamo vedere che qua
i numeri aumentano a dismisura e diventa
quasi esponenziale la cosa
questo sassonero dentro il petto del non
sapere cosa succederà ma da un certo
punto di vista fortunatamente l'universo
è scemo e quindi si auto bilancia per
ogni cosa straziata mente negativa ce
n'era un'altra completamente
rincoglionita se da una parte c'erano i
bollettini giornalieri dall'altra il
ragazzo che ha legato in fater di un
bagno pubblico è risultato positivo al
coronavirus e mi sa tanto che lì in
mezzo il virus è il meno peggio da una
parte viene schierato l'esercito per
controllare le violazioni dall'altra
capisci perché a firenze nell'auto
certificazione scrive devo comprare
droga denunciato visto si passa
praticamente dalla tragedia alla
commedia in un singolo swipe tutta
questa situazione è una enorme
gigantesca puntata di scrubs tanto che
si arrivava anche a capitalizzare
immediatamente con menini sul
coronavirus faccina schifata faccina che
fa l'okay con le dita e schizzo d'acqua
[Musica]
bravi
bari avanti di russi
l'importante è comunque che la gente lo
stia prendendo bene e che riesca a
riceverli informazioni dalle notizie dai
giornalisti in modo chiaro e preciso
l'effetto virus sulle borse è drammatico
tanto che i numerosi appelli per
rimanere a casa hanno l'effetto
contrario stessa cosa per le mascherine
in rete giravano 100.000 notizie diverse
su mettete le mascherine non mettete le
mascherine lasciatele soltanto a chi
deve lavorare la gente ha comprato
talmente tante mascherine che anche
quella di miss cheta esaurì peraltro
discreta due ore 99 la mascherina a caso
a saperlo e su amazon sono rimasti dei
rivenditori stranissime 59 euro 20 pezzi
e oddio nel compro per fortuna però
recentemente ne sono arrivate altre
scorte diciamo tra cui la mia preferita
in assoluto quella con il panda con il
viso umano che indica e sopra una
tragedia in atto
credo che ci sia una storia allora qui
c'è un panda che si è impiccato e si è
suicidato
questi credo siano i parenti questi
credo siano gli amici che hanno
assistito al tutto e a un certo punto
arriva il dottore il medico che fa o con
la faccia e indica una bara dicendo non
hai comprato le nostre mascherina e nel
95 e hai fatto questa fine
e c'è soltanto una recensione con una
stella il costo non è specifica e grazie
alla recensione dell'eroina moderna
emanuela hanno aggiunto il prezzo ad un
certo punto come per ogni cosa
gigantesca si attivano i vip che fanno
partire la campagna io resto a casa io
mi diverto a casa ma anche lì l'universo
ha dovuto bilanciarsi da una parte la
potenza di un hashtag potente come io
resto a casa dall'altra jared leto che
si è accorto in ritardissimo
dell'epidemia del coronavirus perché era
da 12 giorni in meditazione silente nel
deserto sono partite anche una marea di
live
su instagram con vari vip che
interagivano tra di loro io credo nel
mio piccolo e modestamente di aver fatto
lo screenshot perfetto che racchiude lo
spirito di quelle che erano le live tra
vip con jovanotti che fa una live con
riccardo il cantante dei pinguini e
miriana trevisan verificata che fa il
pollice parli su un saluto a miriana tra
l'altro miliana dove se hai ci manchi ma
tra l'altro la gente sa chi sa chi sia
miriana trevisan e chi è vabbè non
importi importantissima è stata la
campagna di raccolta fondi di chiara
ferragni e fede in questo periodo e per
una volta che riescono a fare qualcosa
senza sfiorare la lontano le polemiche
abbiamo tale daniela martani che si
lamenta con tutte le persone che si
congratulano con chiara dicendo
certo tra una foto in mutande con le
gambe per dell'altra
smettetela di incensare sti personaggi
inutili vergognatevi hashtag e chiara
ferragni hashtag coronavirus signorina
daniela martani o martani è la stessa
che su twitter recentissimamente ha
detto che noi vegani siamo immuni al
virus
siccome non mi basta leggere determinate
cose ma io voglio essere più informato
su chi sia una determinata persona
sono andato a cercar mela lei è la
spettacolare autrice di un libro
chiamato anti influencer contro i nuovi
persuasori del nulla con ancora più
curiosità nel corpo sono andato a
informarmi di più su chi fossero
signorina daniele ho scoperto aver
partecipato al grande fratello
il carnevale finisse male e le giornate
passano così con io che nel secondo
schermo mi metto tutti i comizi di conte
che dice di prendere precauzioni in
alternato a me che prendo le precauzioni
mentre mi si bucano i guanti e a
proposito di conte pornhub ha rilasciato
il suo premium gratuitamente e no non
stiamo scherzando
e voi giustamente vi chiederete che
collegamento ci sarà mai tra giuseppe
conte e pornhub due primi un free
giuseppe conte è primo nelle ricerche di
tendenza eccolo qua
subito sotto quarantena e subito dopo
non usare la mascherina con valvola
diffonde il contagio
oh mia bella mascherina
[Musica]
io ti vengono a l'onta chianca verde o
l'azzurrina tutti noi di stian ceriale
[Musica]
c'è un sito che si chiama world home
meters che ha le statistiche in tempo
reale mondiali tra cui recentemente gli
aggiornamenti del coronavirus alla
registrazione di questo video ci sono un
milione di casi 54 mila morti e 218mila
ricoverate e giustamente c'è gente che
non vuole vederli questi dati non riesce
a gestire mentalmente questi dati quindi
se non volete essere bombardati da
queste notizie c'è un sito che vi posso
consigliare io per anche solo un minimo
alleggerirvi le giornate andate su
google e scrivete gigino e un traduttore
napoletano campani in ascolto ditemi se
è giusto perché non ne sono sicurissimo
detto ciò vorrei veramente finire questo
video con un messaggio positivo vorrei
veramente essere una di quelle persone
che esce fuori dal balcone col cartello
andrà tutto bene ma la verità è che non
ne ho idea
l'unica cosa che vi posso dire è quello
che ho detto a me stesso negli ultimi
giorni è giusto avere paura in questo
periodo
grazie mille sperando davvero di
rivederci presto
e quindi capisce signor ezio che sto
cercando veramente in tutti i modi di
creare un contenuto che non sia
completamente inutile per il canale
prima di ripartire con lo show e non so
bene come fare perché è molto difficile
per me non è che avrebbe pettino di
pasta anche per me no perché non so se
iscriverlo non scrivere melo se farlo
elegante o se farlo in casa perché
l'idea di farlo sul desktop
mi sembrava abbastanza carina quindi
sembravano so lei che dice